Quand on parle de cet
arrondissement,
ce qui vient en tête, c'est la
grosse chicane entre Madame
Montgomery et Madame Plante.
C'est allé en cours. C'est un
peu le fond de ce qui se passe
actuellement dans notre dame de
Grasse et Côte-des-Neiges.
Mais il y a d'autres candidats.
Madame Gomery se présente
indépendante, évidemment, elle
n'est plus avec l'équipe de
Madame Plante. Lionel Peres a
été chef de l'opposition à
l'hôtel de ville et il se
présente comme maire
d'arrondissement. Une autre
candidate se présente pour
projet Montréal, la candidate de
Madame Plante. Et un candidat
pour Monsieur Holness, candidat
à la mairie. Jean-Sébastien
Cloutier est allé faire un tour.
De quoi parle-t-on, qu'est-ce
qui préoccupe les citoyens de
cet arrondissement?
Voici.
- Algérien.
- Algérien? Ah, moi, Marocain!
- Marocain?
- Marocain, de Casablanca!
- Casablanca!
- Faire campagne dans Côte-
des-Neiges-Notre-Dame-de-Grâce,
c'est voyager un peu.
La population de
l'arrondissement s'exprime
dans une centaine de langues;
le tiers à peine
est francophone.
(en grec)
Cette bénévole parlait grec
pour solliciter un électeur
lors de notre passage au bureau
de campagne de Lionel Perez.
Le candidat, qui espère devenir
maire d'arrondissement pour
le parti de Denis Coderre,
joue la carte de l'inclusion
et de l'expérience.
LIONEL PEREZ, candidat mairie,
CDN-NDG, Ensemble Montréal
- Mon bilan parle pour
soi-même : 12 ans comme
conseiller municipal,
quatre ans à l'exécutif, chef de
l'opposition pendant quatre ans.
Je connais les rouages
du système.
- Sa priorité s'il est élu :
aller chercher plus d'argent
pour son arrondissement, qui
compte autant de résidents que
toute la ville de Sherbrooke.
- Plus d'argent qui vient de la
ville centre; malheureusement,
il y a un inéquilibre financier
et budgétaire, ça s'est empiré
gravement avec Projet Montréal.
- La mairesse sortante, Sue
Montgomery, a la même priorité.
Élue dans l'équipe de Valérie
Plante en 2017, elle a été
expulsée l'an dernier après
avoir refusé de congédier sa
directrice de cabinet soupçonnée
de harcèlement psychologique
sur deux fonctionnaires.
Sue Montgomery a depuis fondé
son propre parti pour
l'arrondissement.
SUE MONTGOMERY, candidate CDN-
NDG, Équipe Sue Montgomery
- Ils ont oublié
notre arrondissement.
Alors j'aimerais faire
des alliances avec n'importe qui
au centre-ville pour me battre
pour les intérêts de
Côte-des-Neiges-NDG.
- Si elle est réélue,
elle étudierait avec son conseil
d'arrondissement la possibilité
d'aller en cour pour contester
le projet de réforme de
la langue française.
Selon elle, c'est un enjeu pour
les minorités linguistiques.
- Et j'aimerais que tout
le monde ait accès à toutes
les informations dans notre
arrondissement dans leur langue.
- Sue Montgomery est sous
la menace d'une suspension
de quatre mois que souhaite lui
imposer la Commission municipale
du Québec pour 11 manquements
éthiques dans son rôle
de mairesse.
Elle continue de se défendre.
- C'est épouvantable,
ce qui s'est passé dans mon
arrondissement, et je n'accepte
pas qu'un petit boys club
gère mon arrondissement.
- Puis malheureusement pour
elle, elle a une réputation
d'une personne assez difficile.
- Elle a des bonnes idées,
elle communique bien avec
la communauté, je pense
qu'elle va recevoir mon vote.
- It is definitely
more difficult to trust her.
- 1, 2, 3...
- Autre candidate : celle
qui tente de gagner la mairie
d'arrondissement pour Projet
Montréal. Gracia Kasoki Katahwa
est gestionnaire à l'hôpital
St. Mary's.
GRACIA KASOKI KATAHWA, candidate
CDN-NDG, Projet Montréal
- Je suis une infirmière.
Les gens, en fait, ils savent
qu'ils peuvent me faire
confiance, je suis toujours
une citoyenne comme eux,
donc ça, ils apprécient
cet aspect-là. Puis oui, je suis
nouvelle candidate en politique
municipale, mais je suis
une personne qui est très,
très impliquée, engagée.
Vous êtes plus à l'aise
en anglais qu'en français?
C'est comme vous voulez.
- I only speak english.
- No problem, no problem.
Bonjour, enchantée.
- Pour elle, le vivre-ensemble
et l'inclusion passent d'abord
par plus de logements abordables
et de verdissement.
- À contribuer à ce qu'on
améliore la qualité de vie
dans les quartiers, que les gens
soient bien finalement là où ils
habitent. J'ai particulièrement
vu l'importance de ça au cours
de la dernière année et demie,
où on a pris d'assaut carrément
les parcs, par exemple,
les espaces publics parce
qu'on avait, oui besoin
d'être dehors, mais on avait
aussi brsoin de sentir
qu'on vivait en communauté.
- Gracia Katahwa doit maintenant
se faire un nom auprès
des électeurs satisfaits
de Valérie Plante.
- Il faut peut-être qu'elle
fasse un peu plus de...
qu'elle se fasse connaître
davantage parce que vous voyez,
moi, je la connais pas du tout,
j'ai pas entendu...
- Mais vous auriez tendance
à voter pour elle?
- Mais j'aurais tendance
à voter quand même pour elle.
- Moi, ça va me faire plsisir,
comme mairesse d'arrondissement,
de voir...
- Tout en essayant de convaincre
les autres...
- Les gens, ils en ont marre de
ce qu'ils entendent, des frais
des avocats, aller en cour,
et c'est pas terminé!
Ils ne veulent plus de ça!
Ils veulent un maire ou
une mairesse qui s'occupe
des citoyens.
- Les gens ont juste besoin
qu'on arrête de perdre du temps
puis qu'on commence à travailler
pour eux.
- Et dans cet arrondissement
multi-ethnique, le nouveau parti
Mouvement Montréal pourrait-il
séduire bon nombre
d'anglophones?
- Un référendum sur la langue.
- Son chef, Balarama Holness,
propose finalement
une consultation publique pour
décider si Montréal devrait, oui
ou non, abandonner son statut
de ville francophone pour
un statut de ville bilingue.
BALARAMA HOLNESS, candidat
mairie, chef, Mouvement Montréal
- Je crois qu'il faut pouvoir
servir les gens dans
les deux langues et ça se peut
qu'à Côte-des-Neiges-Notre-Dame-
de-Grâce, à cause de
la démographie, oui, cette
proposition a un bénéfice
pour eux, mais aussi à travers
la ville de Montréal.
- Deux fois pendant l'entrevue,
des Montréalais sont venus
l'interrompre...
- Des projets de loi 96,
on voit... Viens, viens.
Tu veux en discuter?
- ... Pour lui signifier
leur désaccord.
Au lieu de favoriser
le vivre-ensemble, ça divise?
- Ça se peut très bien
et je dirais la même chose
au gouvernement provincial,
qui sont en train d'assujettir
la ville de Montréal à des lois
que nous ne sommes pas d'accord
avec.
- Un facteur sera déterminant
dans cette lutte à suivre à
Côte-des-Neiges-Notre-Dame-de-
Grâce : le nombre d'électeurs
qui se déplaceront pour voter.
En 2017, seulement 38 % l'avait
fait, soit 4 % de moins que
la moyenne montréalaise.